قائمه افضل 50 مطعم في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا لعام 20 23 تم الكشف عنها
مؤخرا القائمه السنويه جمعها 200 شخصا من
نخبه رواد قطاع المطاعم في المنطقه تم
اختيارهم بفضل خبراتهم المهنيه في مطاعم
الشرق الاوسط والشمالي افريقيا
تناول الطعام في المنطقه وتميزها
بالماكولاتها لاستثنائيه ومفاهمها الفريده
وتجارب تناول الطعام التي لا مثيل لها
فالحصول على لقب احد افضل 50 مطعم في
المنطقه ليس امرا سهلا يعني المنافسه
شديده والمعايير عاليه للغايه بما في ذلك
جوده الطعام والاصاله وتجربه تناول الطعام
بشكل عام وهذا مطعم
في دبي على جائزه افضل مطعم في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا لعام 20 23
[موسيقى]
الاستوديو تنورنا الاعلام
في جريده الشرق الاوسط اهلا بك مع نفسك
في المنطقه
اول شيء انا حضرت
الحفل يا اللي جرى من يومين بمدينه ابو
ظبي وبالفعل عن جد كان شيء بيشرف جدا لانه
كان بدورته الثانيه يالي تجرى على هذا
الصعيد وعلى هذا النطاق بمشاركه عالميه
يعني جوائز افضل 50 مطعم هي جائزه معروفه
جدا عاده بتكون في جوائز توزع على افضل
100 مطعم بالعالم وهيدي الدوره الثانيه
لجائزه افضل 50 مطعم بالشرق الاوسط بشمال
افريقيا فكان في تواجد كثير
لاسماء كثير كثير بعالم الطهي مثل الشيف
وبالفعل يعني كان انا كعربيه حسيت كثير
بالفخر خاصه انه الرابح كان مطعم عربي
وفعلا هناك كان تركيز على ثقافه المطبخ
العربي في خلال تقديم هذه الجوائز اليوم
جو سليم كمان كان في تركيز اكثر من غيره
على مساله الطبخ المنزلي وبطلنا نحكي على
الفاين دايمنج يعني شو اللي صار ما الذي
تغير همم
باليوم الثاني بالمشارك يعني قبل توزيع
الجوائز والكشف عن اسماء الرابحين كيف شيء
اسمه التوكس او المحادثات حول التعامل
ومستقبل المطبخ في من يقول يعني بانه
الفاين داينينج او المطعم الراقي همم في
طريقه للزواج وفي بعض الاخر بيعتبر انه قد
يبقى ولكن قد تقرا عليه الكثير من
التغيرات ولكن كلنا بنعرف
يكون تجربه ولكن ما فيك هيك اليوم بعدين
في عوده للمستلجيه عوده للحنين للاكل
المنزلي وهذا اللي خلا الشيف السلام دقاق
تربه حجازي افضل طاهيه بالشرق الاوسط لا
المركزت على الطهي المنزلي ان دون ما ننسى
انه الابداع والكريات تريتي كمان مهمين من
هيك ربحت بجايزه ااا شاف مرايا حايك عن ام
شريف ببيروت طب انت حضرتي للمسابقه كيف
شفتي المنافسه بين المطاعم حتى يختاروا 50
مطاعم كانت منافسه كثير كبيره وهو بيشارك
عاده فيها 250 شخص من النقاد اا عاده ما
بيقولوا مين همه
وممنوع للشخص اللي بيكون به بلده ويصوت
للمطعم يا اللي بالبلد اللي هو متواجد فيه
بقى هي بتجرى يعني على مستوى كثير
كثير عاليه المنافسه كانت كثير حلوه ولكن
الاكل هو ثقافي يعني الطعام هو مش بس واحد
لملء المعده اول شيء هلا الكريات كثير
مهمه انا هذا اللي كثير
تاريخ كثير حلو
يركزوا اكثر على المذاق وعلى النكهه ومش
على الشكل ولكن بهالايام بتشوف لانه في
تركيز اكثر كمان على الشكل وعلى الابداع
النظري طيب جوسيلين شو اليوم بيفرق هيك
نوع جوايز عن مثلا ستار اللي بتعطى
للمطاعم بالماضي وانا كنت من انا بما انه
يعني متخصصه بالكتابه
الطهي والمطعم همم كان عندي دائما عتب على
مش لانقايد انه ليش ما بيحطوا فيه ما
بيضمنه مطاعم عربيه وخاصه يعني مطاعم
العربيه معروفه جدا فمره اتصلت بدليل مش
لان وقال انه راح بيكون في نوع من ضمن
هالمطاعم ولكن عندنا احنا بالمنطقه
العربيه في شويه مشاكل ممكن تكون سياسيه
هذا اللي بيخلي دليل المشكله
الدم بعد المطاعم دي لندن تحديدا واعطاهم
ما يعرف مش بنجمه ميشلان ولكن ما يعرف
بالفلورات اه اوكي او طيب اوجاسمين كمان
في مساله الاطباق اللي لها علاقه
بالاستدام اليوم شيء بنحكي بها الخصوص
السنه مثل
الدوره الثانيه لافضل 50 مطعم بشمال
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط كيف في التركيز على
نقطتين النقطه الاولى كانت اللاكجيري
ومفهومه
اللاكجيريا او الفاينداي عينيك والنقطه
الثانيه كانت التركيز على الاستدامه او
ال- تكون انه
كثير حبيته انه في اكثر من مطعم من منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وبالتحديد دبي وبالاردن همم
اخذوا اخذوا جوايز عن الاستدانه والحفاظ
على البيئه وهذا يعني انه ما يكون في همم
التفريط في اي مواد تستخدم في المطبخ لانه
من زمان كان حتى الخضار يستعمله اصلا منه
ويرموا القسم الثاني
تعني انه الاستفاده من كل قطعه باي منتج
يستخدم في المطبخ شكرا جزيلا كنت معنا في
الاستوديو الاعلاميه الصحفيه في جريده
الشرق الاوسط شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
الطاهيه الفلسطينيه سلام صاحبه مطعم بيت
مريم في دبي استطاعت ان تفوز بجائزه افضل
طهيه في منطقه شرق الاوسط بعد التصويت
الذي سجلته اكاديميه افضل خمسين مطعما في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا وهي جائزه لن
يسبق لاي احد من المنطقه العربيه الحصول
عليها تتميز اطباق الشيف سلام بانها تجول
حول عده بلدان عربيه من الخليج الذي عاشت
فيه الى بلاد الشام الذي اتت منها فهي
تقدم اطباقا تقليديه يعشقها العرب طريقه
استقبال الشاف سلام للزبائن هي اكثر ما
تشتهر به فهي تعتبر لان الاستقبال هو اول
ما يجب على الطهي الجيد ان يتمتع به وتشدد
على اهميه معامله الزبائن بطريقه حميميه
وكسر الحواجز وتشعرهم وكانهم ياكلون في
المنزل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وتنورنا بحضورها معانا في الاستديو اليوم
شايف سلام دقائق شايف اهلا بك
مبروك عليك الفوز الله يبارك فيك
كيف كان شعورك بهذا الفوز اول شيء صباح
الخير ويسعد صباحكم شكرا لاستضافتي اييه
كان شعور كثير رائع صراحه كانت في حفاوه
مش معقوله يمكن انا ما سمعتها
ورائي همم
الحضور كلها الحفله كانت جميله جدا
انبسطت كثير طبعا
يعني كمان جوائز متزوجه كمان شاف سلام همم
بيفورز نساء ملهمات فوق الخمسين يعني كله
جوائز واحتفالات السعاده والنجاح دائما
اه يعني دائما عندك الاهتمام والدلال قبل
فكره الاكله شو بتحكي لنا
بدوله ام المطاعم يعني
ما بدي اكسر قاعده انه بس بدنا نفوت على
المطعم ناكل ونطلع لا انا بدي احسس كل
زبون وهذا ما بيلاقيم اطباقي انك انت فايت
على بيتك انا عامله وظيفه امن همم بدي
اكسر حاجه اني انا فاتح على مطعم بدي اكل
بس الصحن بالسكينه لا فوت على البيت تحس
حالك مرتاح كلنا محتاجين لهاي الروح
الحلوه همم
صاحبه المطعم موجوده ترحاب كان كثير وحلو
فريحهم نوع
اكل بيتي واحنا بطبيعتنا
نظيف كثير طيب
يمكن اول شيء كلها
فريش كلياتها اممم
البرودات
فانا كل يوم فعلا بطبخ الطبخه كانه لولادي
عشان يجوا يستمتعوا وينكم حتى لما بتعاملي
الناس بنشوف على السوشيال ميديا بتدللي
لهم كانهم اولادي يعني هذا اللي بنحتاجه
بالغربه
همم نفس الاكل نفس
دقيقه
له علاقه الرسم بالطبخ الفن كله
[موسيقى]
المقادير مع بعض بالضبط النكهات كيف تطلع
بورتك الملحات البهارات تبعونها هذا كله
في تقنيه يعني
واحنا اكيد راح يكون لنا زياره ان شاء
الله
بتشرف فيكم عنجد ونحن اكثر هو بيتكم وشكرا
لوجودك معنا وشكرا لوقتك حبيبتي
يسعد صباحكم
[موسيقى]